on a date we're looking at each other's
faces
and one of the things that's interesting
is as we scan
we also look at the lips when we're very
comfortable around each other
the lips are full these little folds
called the pillows fill with blood when
we're comfortable around each other so
much so
that when we kiss we actually feel
the warmth
my name is joe navarro and i am a
non-verbal communications expert
when it comes to dating most of our
decisions are really based on
non-verbals
how they look does this person have a
nice
manner are they well behaved we cannot
escape this this is
part of our being human
you know every time we walk by somebody
we're interested in and we groom
ourselves and preen ourselves
in a way this is part of that heritage
of presenting ourselves at our best so
that we will be
considered
so let's look at this couple on their
first date
it's interesting times so as we
watch these two individuals the first
thing we'll notice is
they're both a little nervous and that's
to be expected
and the reason for that is when we come
into visual range
we are both assessing each other the
limbic area of the brain is doing the
major
processing it is looking at this other
person for those
features that say is this person a
threat to me or are they not a threat to
me
do they look healthy respectful are they
well
mannered do they look well groomed
things like this
this is the magical process
that we all engage in of grabbing
as much information about this person
before we even begin to talk to them
[Music]
as we get closer then we begin to assess
each other's faces we're looking at each
other to see
if the person is attractive to see
if we can have a harmonious moment
and in part it has to do with the fact
that
we have this visual cortex if if you
make a fist that's about the size of
your visual cortex
that visual cortex wants to be fed
and it's not just us uh many animals for
instance
lionesses uh prefer the lion that has
the large mane and so it tends to be
very universal that we have a preference
for that which is beautiful and which
stands out
in fact when i see someone that's
absolutely
beautiful my pupils dilate
we don't have control over that we know
that because we've done studies on
babies and their
pupils dilate when they see something
beautiful
so the more that we like each other the
more of the scanning
that takes place you can certainly see
the man
scanning the woman and usually that
scanning
is eye to eye to nose
to mouth to throat back up to the eyes
and it's this triangle look at how often
they're scanning
each other versus i'm looking at you one
second
and then i'm totally looking away and
back and forth
[Music]
as we see from the video there comes a
point where
they stopped being sort of restless they
sort of settled down
and they've now transitioned from
getting acquainted and getting situated
to
the conversation in earnest one of the
first things that stood out for me at
the two-minute mark
is you see her leg stretched out which
is
a terrific indicator that she's very
much interested in this individual
because otherwise that leg would never
go out that far
it would remain restrained this is
a very limbic response which at a
subconscious level
says i'm willing to spend more time with
you
so much so that i'm on one leg and off
balance
that it's towards him is very positive
because when we're getting along with
each other
we're going to see more reaching out
towards the person i'm talking to
and these are similitudes of
i wish we were closer together
we're very comfortable we tend to touch
things we may actually
touch ourselves whether it's our watch
or our hands or a purse or something
we become more tactile because our body
is asking us to contribute to the
positive nature of what's going on
and that's what we're seeing here you'll
see some self-adjusting on her part
to make herself even more comfortable
conversely
we see the man rubbing his hands on his
knee
so they seem in a position where
they can feel comfortable with
themselves and with the other person
hand gestures are so much part of
communication
because they help to convey a story
visually but they also represent our
emotions
let's say a woman is playing with her
hair
as she is talking to a man and if she
likes the man
what we'll see is that she'll rotate her
wrist
so that when she plays now with her hair
the inside of the wrist
is now facing the man in the old days
when a lot more people were smoking
you would smoke this way but the minute
you like the person with you then you
would
rotate the wrist towards that person
as the date continues we begin to see a
lot of ventral fronting and
and so forth when we like people we turn
and rotate
our ventral side towards them the limbic
system is not going to permit you
to front your ventral your weakest side
to something that you dislike at a very
young age you'll see a young child maybe
two three years old immediately cross
their arms turn around
and go i don't want to go and you say
where did you learn that behavior
it's innate
as we move along what you notice is that
every time
she moves he moves she moves he moves
this is clearly
isopraxis going on this is true
body echoing their bodies are mirroring
each other
we know that there is synchrony and when
there's synchrony there's
harmony just before the 11 minute mark
we see them laughing
simultaneously and that is
probably one of the most apparent
displays that we have as humans
of we are in synchrony it's kind of a
beautiful dance to watch especially when
you look at it at rapid speed
when one touches the face such as at the
13 minute mark
the other one touches the face and so
forth as you
move between 30 and 33 minutes you'll
notice that the quick head movements
that she makes
are mirrored almost perfectly by the
same head movements that he makes
which again is indicative of
psychological comfort and harmony
we can tell that there's a lot of
interest we see them
leaning in we see them expressing
themselves
and so forth these behaviors are
very much consistent with what we would
say
hey they're they're getting along
even to the casual observer several
things stand out
they both remained in place for
a considerable period of time they
mirrored each other
they took comfort in each other their
body language is communicating we're
getting along
we're interested in each other and
that's the beauty of nonverbal
communications is that
i didn't have to listen to what they
said i was looking
at what they were shouting through their
body language and their body
language was saying we are in harmony